hay un tercer tipo de problemas de
descomposición en fracciones parciales
así que pienso que sería buena idea
verlos por sí que los encuentras por ahí
en algún momento en estos problemas
tenemos un factor repetido en el
denominador así que déjame poner un
ejemplo dice 6x al cuadrado menos 19 x
más 15 más 15 / / / x menos 1 x menos 1
por x menos 2 al cuadrado y este término
es lo que lo hace interesante porque
tenemos un factor repetido en el
denominador bueno vamos a hacer la
expansión en fracciones parciales el
primer paso ver que el numerador tenga
grado menor que el denominador aquí si
pasa porque arriba es de grado 2 y abajo
es de grado 3 10 grado 2 grado 1
multiplicados dan grado 3 lo puedes
verificar por tu cuenta ahora uno podría
pensar que al hacer el desarrollo en
fracciones parciales esto va a ser igual
a una cierta constante le voy a poner a
dividida entre x menos 1
más otra constante ve dividida entre x2
más otra constante c otra vez dividida
entre x menos 2 pero esto no va a
funcionar si intentamos hacer esto
simplemente vamos a sumar la b con la c
y en el denominador nos va a quedar x
menos 2 y nunca va a aparecer el x menos
2 al cuadrado entonces tenemos que hacer
otra cosa más vale entonces te voy a
contar cómo se hace esa va a ser la
respuesta y después vas a pensar un
poquito en por qué funciona eso vale
bueno el chiste es que si tenemos que
tener estos tres sumandos pero aquí en
el tercero el x menos 2 tiene que estar
elevado al cuadrado vale entonces
tenemos que tener estos tres suman dos
más o menos la intuición detrás de poner
este cuadrado es que si hacemos la suma
de estos dos arriba nos va a quedar algo
lineal abajo algo cuadrática y eso va a
coincidir con lo que hicimos en el vídeo
pasado es más déjame déjame hacerlo
déjame sumar estos dos de acá nada más
van a ser estos 2
con este y más o menos la idea es que al
realizar la suma nos va a quedar algo
del estilo una constante por x más otra
constante dividido entre x2 al cuadrado
y entonces tenemos algo lineal de grado
1 entre algo cuadrática de grado 2
entonces bueno esto es más o menos lo
que hacíamos en el vídeo pasado y esta
es la intuición detrás pero bueno
podríamos pasarnos mucho tiempo
platicando pero mejor te dejo para que
lo pienses déjame borrar esto y ya que
sabemos que se tiene que escribir así
con estos tres sumandos ahora sí vamos a
resolver el problema entonces cómo le
hacemos para determinar a b y c que
cumplan con esta igualdad pues lo mismo
que hemos hecho en los vídeos pasados
vamos a realizar la suma de este lado
este con este con este entonces al lado
derecho vamos a hacer la suma de
expresiones racionales y para eso
necesitamos un denominador común
necesitamos un factor x menos 1
necesitamos un x2 pero tiene que estar
elevado al cuadrado por este sumando
entonces x2 al cuadrado y ahora hay que
cambiar cada uno de estos sumandos vale
entonces esta y bueno aquí abajo tenía
un x menos 1 le pusimos un x menos 2 al
cuadrado entonces se tiene que convertir
en a por x menos 2 elevado al cuadrado
sale en realidad este con este se
cancelan y tenemos este sumando original
vamos con el de enmedio aquí ya tenemos
un x menos 2 nos falta otro y un x menos
uno entonces nos queda b por x menos uno
por x menos 2
y finalmente hay que sumarse si ya
tenemos el x2 al cuadrado y falta un x1
por equis menos uno vale otra vez x1 se
cancela con x1 y nos queda se entre x2
al cuadrado y que hacemos ahora pues lo
mismo que hemos hecho en los dos vídeos
pasados ya tenemos que los denominadores
son iguales de la primera y la última
expresión ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es igualar los numeradores para poder
encontrar a b y c entonces déjame
igualar los numeradores nos queda que 6x
al cuadrado 6x al cuadrado menos 19 x
más 15 más 15 es igual a por x menos 2
al cuadrado más b por x menos 1 por x
menos 2
por x 2 + c por x ó y teniendo esta
igualdad ya podemos sustituir algunos
valores estratégicos de x que nos
permitan cancelar algunas de las
variables y con eso podemos encontrar la
tercera vale bueno vamos a ver qué
valores de x pueden ayudar por ejemplo
si ponemos aquí igual a 1 este se
cancela este se cancela y podemos
despejar
vamos a ver cómo le hacemos para eso
vale entonces le voy a poner que x es
igual a 1 entonces si x es igual a 1 en
el lado izquierdo nos queda 6 menos 19
mar 15 y en el lado derecho nos queda a
por uno menos 2 que es menos 1 al
cuadrado que es uno nada más dejó la más
0 0
esto se hace en 0 vale aquí hay un cero
aquí hay un cero entonces hay seis más
15 19 6 más 15 221 - 19 2 entonces es
igual a 2
muy bien ya tenemos el valor de a ahora
parece ser que también es buena idea
sustituir x igualados porque este se
cancela y éste se cancela y podemos
encontrarse entonces vamos a hacer eso
vamos a poner ahora x igual a 2 si x es
igual a 2
aquí nos queda 6 por 2 al cuadrado 2 al
cuadrado es 4 6 por 4 es 24
- 38 que es 19 por 215 y eso es igual a
éste se cancela este se cancela y nos
queda por dos menos uno o sea nada más
ahora le están quedando muy sencillas
las las cuentas eso está padre bueno
entonces se es 24 15 menos 38 24 15 39
menos 38 es 1 entonces se es igual a un
muy bien que es igual a 1
y finalmente tenemos que encontrar ve
pero si ponemos uno o dos entonces ve se
elimina entonces debemos de poner otro
valor no es obvio poner un valor para
que se cancelen a hice así que mejor
vamos a poner un valor que simplemente
haga las cuentas sencillas vamos a poner
x igual a cero eso siempre hace las
cuentas sencillas entonces si ponemos x
igual a cero éste se hace cero éste se
hace cero y aquí nos queda un 15 15 es
igual a ya conocemos el valor de 62
entonces dos por cero menos dos que es
menos dos al cuadrado que es cuatro
menos 2 por menos dos es cuatro más por
menos uno por menos dos aquí nos quedan
menos 12 estamos poniendo x igual a cero
más c por menos uno pero se es uno y
tenemos que ponerlo por menos uno
entonces tenemos esta expresión vamos a
simplificar un poco nos queda que 15 es
igual a 8 más menos 1 por menos dos es
22 b - 1 - 1 y aquí podemos bueno 8 - 17
restamos 7 de ambos lados nos queda que
dos veces igual a 8 2 b es igual a 8 y
por lo tanto b lo voy a poner aquí b es
igual a dividimos entre 2 nos queda 4 b
es igual a 4 muy bien entonces con esto
ya tenemos los valores de a b y c que
hacen que funcione esta expansión o bien
esta descomposición en fracciones
parciales entonces nada más déjame
reescribir la expresión acá
un color blanco para que veamos que ya
es la respuesta entonces la
descomposición es 2 dividido entre x
menos uno más bx 44 dividido entre x
menos 2 más sé que es uno más
bueno aquí podría quitarle los
paréntesis lo voy a dejar así más uno
dividido entre x menos 2 x menos 2
elevado al cuadrado vale entonces este
de aquí ya es el desarrollo o la
descomposición en fracciones parciales
en realidad esta idea de repetir
factores y poner en los sumandos que va
creciendo se puede aplicar cuando este
grado es mayor a 2 osea déjame déjame
dar un pequeño ejemplo así más o menos
esbozado entonces no sé si tuviéramos
algo del estilo un polinomio dividido
entre vamos a ponerle x menos a la 10 no
10 es muy grande bueno sí porque no 10
a la 10 entonces podemos utilizar
exactamente el mismo truco o la misma
estrategia esto en la expansión o el
desarrollo en fracciones parciales se
puede escribir como una constante
dividido entre x menos a más
otra constante dividido entre x menos a
al cuadrado y aquí tenemos que seguir
otra constante dividido entre x menos al
cubo vamos al cubo y así sucesivamente
hasta pues aquí tendríamos que usar la
décima letra en la décima letra del
abecedario creo que es jota si eso está
dividido entre x menos a elevado a la 10
vale entonces bueno esta técnica de ir
aumentando los exponentes del
denominador funciona aunque tengamos un
grado más grande vale y en realidad
bueno esto sí fue un poco más latoso y
es muy raro que te encuentres un
problema así éste requería muchísimas
cuentas y no es el chiste bueno al menos
no en un examen en un examen te vas a
encontrar máximo un problema como como
este que acabamos de hacer aquí arriba
oa lo mejor como el que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado pero usualmente si queremos
hacer cosas más complicadas que eso como
algo de grado 10 tenemos que usar la
computadora vale bueno pero aunque uses
la computadora es bueno saber cómo se
hacen los casos chiquitos en fin espero
que te hayan gustado estos problemas y
que te haya servido para entender un
poco más acerca de la descomposición en
fracciones parciales